what I want to do in this video is
explore the notion of a matrix outside
of the context of a surprisingly good
movie that involves Keanu Reeves and
it's actually the first of three I guess
we could call the three movies combined
the matrices and there is a relationship
between the movie which is about a
virtual reality constructed by
super-smart computers and the relation
and the notion of what a matrix is when
you study it in mathematics or when you
study it in computer science and then
the connection really is is that
matrices are used a lot when you are
simulating things or when you're
constructing things in computer science
especially in frankly computer graphics
so the super intelligent robots that
made the the matrix in the movie matrix
we're probably using matrices in order
to do it if they actually did exist now
what is a matrix then well that's a
fairly simple answer it's just a
rectangular array of numbers so for
example this right over here if I have 1
0 negative 7pi 5 and I don't know 11
this is a matrix this is a matrix where
1 0 negative 7pi each of those are an
entry in the matrix this matrix right
over here has two rows two rows and it
has three three columns and because it
has two rows and 3 columns people will
often say that this is a 2 by 3 matrix
whenever they say it's a something by
something matrix they're telling you
that it has two rows so you see the two
rows right over there and they are
telling you and they're telling you that
it has three columns you see the three
columns right over there
I could give you other examples of a
matrix so I could have I can have a one
by one matrix so I could have the matrix
one this right over here is a one by one
matrix has one row one column I could
have a matrix like this 3 7 and 17 what
is this well this has one row this is
one row we see here and it has three
columns this is a one by three matrix I
could have a matrix and I think you see
where all of this is going figuring out
the dimensions of matrix are not too
difficult I could
matrix that looks like this where it's 3
5 0 0 negative 1 negative 7 this is 7
negative 7 this right over here has 3
rows so it's 3 rows and it has 2 2
columns so we would call this a 3 by 2
let me do that in that same color we
would call it a 3 a 3 by 2 matrix 3 rows
and 2 columns so fair enough
you know that a matrix is just a
rectangular a rectangular array of
numbers you can say what its dimensions
are you know that each of these numbers
that take one of these positions we just
call those entries but what are matrices
good for I still might not be clear what
the connection is between this and this
right over here and at the most
fundamental level these are just ways
this is just a compact representation of
a bunch of numbers it's a way of
representing information they become
very valuable in computer graphics
because these numbers could represent
these numbers could represent the color
intensity at a certain point they could
represent whether an object is there at
a certain point and as we develop an
algebra around matrices and when we talk
about developing an algebra around
matrices we're going to talk about
operations that we're going to perform
on matrices that we would normally
perform with numbers so we're going to
learn how we're going to essentially
define how to multiply matrices how to
add matrices how to even take will learn
about taking or an inverse of a matrix
and by coming up with an algebra of how
we manipulate these things it'll become
very useful in the future when you're
trying to write a computer graphics
program or you're trying to do an
economic simulation or probability
simulation to say oh I have this matrix
that represents where different
particles are in space or I have this
matrix that represents the state of some
type of some type of a game and I know
the algebra of matrices and I know ways
of doing it very efficiently so that I
can multiply a bunch of them or I could
come run a simulation and I can actually
come up with useful results so that's
all matrices are but as you'll see
through this they you we can we can
define operations on them and then later
on when you take a linear algebra course
in college you'll learn a lot more of
the
of how they can be applied and what you
can use them to represent